oh man five hours total on this thing
like I I don't know is there really
anything that can justify that kind of
runtime hey folks patreon sponsored
review a sort of this one actually was
someone who got in touch with me
directly but basically did a commission
through PayPal as opposed to doing it
through patreon but it's effectively the
same thing so um uh Bahubali this what I
got commissioned to watch this my
initial reaction was okay I know nothing
about Indian cinema zero like I know a
little bit about the trappings of
Bollywood films which is to say
obviously I've seen Slumdog Millionaire
but the first thing is worth pointing
out is technically this is not a
Bollywood film because that's actually
not a genre in India that is specific to
films made in Bombay that's where the
term comes from Bombay Hollywood
Bollywood so this isn't actually
technically one of those but it is the
highest grossing well I think
technically the second part because this
was done as two films is the highest
grossing film in India made in India and
the second highest grossing Indian film
worldwide so this was kind of a big deal
I am NOT gonna try and pronounce like
anybody's name just cuz I'm gonna
butcher it and it's gonna be bad for
everybody involved so let me state that
much up from but like is it I know
almost nothing about this going in and I
just knew this was long this was two
movies at about two and a half hours
each
so I didn't know what I was gonna get
what I got I am struggling slightly to
figure out how to describe it
let's start with I'm glad I've seen this
because and like again this is not gonna
be a culture perspective I don't I
cannot put any of what I'm about to talk
about into the proper context of the
country was made in or the genre that's
a part of I have no background I just
watched this thing cold and that
honestly may be the best way to watch it
because I'm not I have literally have
almost nothing else to compare it to if
I really wanted to stretch I I could say
here's what I would say it brought to
mind seeing other foreign films and this
happens to me on occasion I don't see a
ton of foreign films but on occasions
where I see something where I feel like
it's really steeped in a culture that I
know I'm not a part of so to make a
comparison that might be slightly odd
watching this it was kind of like
watching the marriage of Kung Fu Hustle
and Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon so if
you've seen those imagine almost Kung Fu
Hustle levels of insanity but Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon
sincerity because Kung Fu Hustle much as
I loved it knew it was funny and knew it
was a joke and knew it was comedy but
this thing is dead serious but it is
nuts so ok plot I was actually kind of
delighted to find out that this is a
completely original plot because it's
presented in a way and it has the kind
of mythic air to it that I initially
assumed and I checked this after
watching the first of the two films
called Bahubali the beginning the other
one being Bahubali of the conclusion
very snazzy but after watching the first
one I looked up because I kind of
assumed oh this must be an adaptation of
like a long-running legends or myth
because it had the air of like the ten
commandments or something it had that
kind of it had all these moments that
felt like there were these big iconic
mythic moments that had always been part
of history and we're now being put up on
screen and then I find out it's an
original creation and an original story
I'm sure probably informed by a lot of
mythology and folklore and other
cultural stuff from the region that I
just don't know about but strictly
speaking it's not an adaptation of
existing stuff which I was kind of
shocked to find out so as far as the
story goes this is a I suppose
technically you who call it a historical
fantasy action epic the fantasy I'm
gonna put an asterisk on because this
isn't like there aren't like monsters or
you know gods showing up or it's nothing
like that but I kind of want to put
fantasy on there because though the
things that human beings are capable of
doing well I'll make the comparison to
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon again you
have to admit to a certain amount of
fantasy in that because people are doing
things like yeah nobody can do that and
that is very much going on here the the
core characters the things that they are
capable of especially in physical combat
is just it's superhero level stuff but I
wouldn't ever call this a superhero
movie again it is it is a historical
setting it has that more sort of epic
vibe that sort of ten commandments Lord
of the Rings sort of feel and vibe to it
so as far as the story goes the it
starts out with this baby being you know
carried away by this woman who is being
attacked and ultimately she dies saving
this baby who is then adopted into this
village in this village lit exists at
the bottom of these waterfalls and these
waterfalls go up so high that they go
past the clouds and some of the people
in the village wonder if there even is
actually a top to those things so
eventually he grows up and he they call
him Shiva but he
he will eventually find out title
character
Bahubali is both his name and his father
well it might I don't exactly know how
naming in Indian culture works but is
the name he both he and his father who
he does not know have although they also
have different I don't know if it's
considered a first name or but they're
both kind of called that and so he gets
up there and he discovers a kingdom
being ruled by a tyrant being fought
against by resistance who is trying to
rescue and free this queen that the
tyrant has been imprisoning for 25 years
and it turns out that baahubali is the
son of the tyrants brother who died in
order for the tyrant to take power and
it then launches into a very extended
flashback what I say very extended I
mean about the last hour of the first
movie and the first two hours of the
second movie which that's something that
I'm gonna acknowledge but I'm also gonna
say this is probably largely a cultural
thing because I actually had like
flashbacks that go on that long tend to
not sit well with me but I don't want to
judge this one because I I honestly have
the same criticism of Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon which has a very extended
flashback sequence not nearly the
extended as this and also hero does
something similar so I think there's
just something about Eastern
storytelling that just does that more
but for me it does kind of take the
stakes up because we basically take the
the end of the first film ends on it's
not really a cliffhanger but it's it's a
it's a it's a truth bomb and then it
takes the first two hours of the second
movie to get us to the point we already
found out at the end of the first one
now it's still nuts and really
credible to watch and fun but it is a
bit like yet but but we know we know but
we know where it's but again like I not
knowing the cultural context of this
kind of storytelling I'm not going to
harp on that too much so but hubli as a
character is the the actor who plays him
whose name I will put up cuz I'm not
come to try and pronounce that the only
reason I am confident saying but who
believes cuz they say it out loud so
often in the movie I actually caught
that the pronunciation on that decently
I think he is an immensely charming and
charismatic presence on the screen he
has one of those smiles that's up there
like with Jon Pertwee and the rock the
kind of smile that it's just like oh and
like the screen lights up which is
actually really good because as a
character especially Bahubali the
younger but also the elder because
they're effectively the same character
not a ton of difference in
characterization just in personal
history but who basically either one of
them basically is the best at everything
the strongest the smartest the most
noble the most compassionate that like
everything the best at everything which
normally would mark out a boring
character it would mark out a Mary Sue
effectively because like literally
everything he tries to do he succeeds
but there's something about the the
smile that he has there's something
about the joy he takes in accomplishing
something because even though he can do
almost everything he can't always do it
on the first try he does have to try for
some of this stuff which also helps but
there's a joy in doing well and doing
right that exudes off him as a person
which is good because as far as his
ability to basically always be the
strongest the smartest the most clever
etc likens to Conan the Barbarian in the
books not so much in the films but
that's very much sort of conan shtick -
but thankfully unlike Conan and Conan
derivatives
Bahubali is not a broody bugger
he takes absolute joy in all of this
which is wonderful again because I see
that he has that wonderful vibrant
presence that's terrific
and the female the female characters in
the in these movies are badasses so like
I don't really consider this to be
spoilers because it's literally the
first scene of the movie but you
remember I said there was the woman who
has baby
Bahubali and we see her you know
traveling with us and then we see
there's an arrow sticking out of her
back then she gets attacked by by these
soldiers and with an arrow in her back
holding a baby
many just to disarm and kill them
eventually she gets swept away down the
waterfalls and she's realizing she is
going she is going to drown she can't
save herself but she basically says a
prayer and holds the baby up above the
water
she is dead she is drowned but her arm
stays up holding this kid above water
which is both the kinds of stuff
something like I said before is the
strongest and everything I so like
helping erect a statue almost by himself
like a freaking hundred foot tall statue
kind of deal that's the kind of stuff
that we're talking about here and and
he's not the only one there's there's
some other very cool characters who did
this sort of stuff he has some and this
is this might also be part of the reason
why the extended flashback threw me off
a bit but Bulli the younger has this
really great relationship that he
develops with this young woman who's
part of the sort of the resistance force
and they're sort of courtship scenes I
thought were Wonder
and fascinating because they kept kind
of coming up to the edge of being
something that I would have been that I
would have cringed at but then managed
to just slightly sidestep it largely on
the basis of the guys charm so I can
think of two examples so they are
fighting and it's not vastly dissimilar
from the from the sword fight in mask of
zorro you know where Joe kind of
eventually just robes her with with the
sword Mobley is kind of removing parts
of her outfit um and but he does other
things was he like squeezes he's very so
his fingers are ready wife's across her
lips and out her lips are red he takes
black like it basically applies makeup
to her and that's like when I realize
that was going on it's like that's I'm
not sure about that but then she stops
and she looks at herself in this
reflective water and you can through the
performance you and and a little bit of
footage from before and suddenly you
realize oh he's helping her see her own
beauty cuz she doesn't think she's
beautiful but now she's looking at that
going oh my god that's me I didn't know
and all that comes across in performance
and it takes something that could have
been kind of skeevy and makes it work or
another thing he has a line like she
gets given this this task that is
incredibly dangerous and all this other
stuff and you know he has this line
where he says you are mine now and I was
like oh God cuz I thought he was gonna
go I forbid you to do it he says your
burdens are now my burdens I will do
this and I rest oh okay so like I mean
if you're gonna do that angle that's the
kind of noble decent human being way to
do that okay cool
and the thing's just full of that um
there was there there was one thing that
that did sort of genuinely make me
uncomfortable in the end of the the
first film ends with basically a 45
minute extended battle which is the
action highlight of the entire thing
it's like helms deep scale and really
well-executed really cool watching the
battle strategy happen in that and there
and really none of the action scenes
after that one quite measure up to it
although other ones are fun later but
any
by the force that the good guys are
fighting against is this collection of
actors who have very clearly been
darkened as far as their skin tone goes
and have had their teeth blackened and
are speaking and I did check is a
made-up and invented language but that
also uses things like clicks and stuff
that at least personally I've only ever
heard in you know like tribal African
languages again I like I don't know
about the history of like I don't want
to call it blackface because I feel like
you say blackface that's a pretty
specific thing from American historical
culture so I don't but I don't know what
else to call it
they clearly darkened up these horrible
skeevy we need them to appear less human
so it's so it's fine that we kill so
many of them kind of characters in that
did make me a little uncomfortable but
again I don't know about the history of
that kind of thing in India so I don't
want to i i'm not gonna saddle it with
the same baggage that i would an
american film because i don't I just
don't know and especially with a film
like this which is it's not like they
were necessarily planning to they
weren't making it for an American
audience so you know making it at an
Indian film for an Indian audience I
don't know if that same baggage is there
but it did make me uncomfortable beyond
that there's just really great
characters oh no there was one other
thing there's there is only one
character with a physical disability in
this and like he's got it like a
shriveled hand and he is a cowardly you
know skeevy creep but if you're going to
show a physically disabled character you
can have them be the bad guy that's fine
but it is a little weird when a film
this big with this many characters only
one of them has a disability and he's
this skeevy
it is a little bit like an that what
that one was just like a little bit of
it that didn't bother me as much as the
the darkened skin thing did that that
that that one did get me a little bit
but certain moving on from that there's
a ton of great characters from you know
the the Queen Mother of Bahubali the
elder and his brother who is in present
time the the current king the thing is
like the time is actually totally easy
to follow it's just hard to explain and
in this sort of video format rambling as
I do you know there are multiple great
female characters we will eventually in
the flashback meet boo who believe the
younger his mother is a really great
character the courtship between her and
and but who believed the elder that's
really well done it's really sweet there
is a very honor bound character who is
very clearly a good guy but is so
devoted to doing his duty that he is
really conflicted on a lot of stuff he's
really good the action scenes are
incredible there's a lot of CGI in this
and it's not always convincing CGI but
the whole thing is so heightened it
doesn't need to be photorealistic to
still work and it absolutely works um
and being new to Indian cinema I can
confirm yes there are large over-the-top
musical numbers pretty much out of
nowhere and they're all great like but I
have nothing else to say I loved that
like when the first one kicked in it's
actually just this little brief bit of
movie the younger just sort of doing
this little dance on his own while while
other characters watch him and kind of
you know do do a little bit of keeping
rhythm and the music kicks up and it all
goes into slow-mo there's a lot of
slow-mo in this thing too but it's just
my face just like this is so much fun
and that's the thing as long as this is
it is a lot of fun now I do pretty much
binge through Bo
these films in a day you don't have to
it's actually fairly segmented even like
within say the two-hour flashback
it is still broken out into clear
segments like oh here's the bit where
the brothers are chasing somebody here's
the bit where behula the elder is
courting this woman here's the bit where
these characters are battling so if you
want to take it in smaller chunks the
entirety of the thing it's very doable
to watch in that way it almost has a
miniseries feel in a way you can find
places where it's segments off every 20
minutes half hour or so so if the
runtime intimidates you that is I think
a perfectly viable way to consider
watching these films um but you do need
to be prepared to watch both it's not
like you can watch one it's not like
Star Wars and New Hope where it's a
complete stories like know it very much
ends unfinished but I think I'll wrap it
up there Bahubali I didn't know what
this was I really did enjoy the heck out
of it eh it's currently on Netflix so
and it's available for streaming easy to
watch to start to check out um there's
no dub at least if there was I do I
don't think there was a checked on the
first one I didn't check on the second
one but you know the it's it's good it's
good acting give it if you like taking
in other cultures stuff including their
weirdness give it a shot I'm glad I got
commissioned for this one have you seen
this thing or have you heard of it or do
you know anything about Indian cinema
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do as
well like subscribe share this video
support me on patreon if you are able to
that is a massive massive help but any
of the other things we'll do as well
there's a link to my merch store down
there there's links to other things that
I do click on them they'll take you
places or don't because at the end of
the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]